so thank you all for your patience on
those little uh
things that happen we are running a
little bit ahead because of that but we
want to go ahead and get started
thank you to that global community we
heard some really exciting updates from
india and africa
and uh we're now going to see
how bio
informatics as a field is evolving here
in the us and the americas
as well as i said in the general
americas welcome to the americas section
of the omiks research symposium why are
we here
well we know you have an interest in how
omiks are being used around the world
and over the next several hours you'll
hear from world-renowned experts in
various omics fields from the broadest
uses of omix to areas of incredible
drill down niches so
stay tuned
my name is grant and i am your host for
this afternoon and i'd love to see where
every once everyone is from
so if you would take a moment to drop a
hello i'd love to see it in your native
tongue because i'm sure we have some
international
people on the call
drop a hello in your native tongue and
maybe your
country or locale in english if you
would drop that in the chat box i would
love to see that if we could get some
responses there i know i saw some people
from africa earlier went in that mode
but uh can we get some responses in the
chat box that would be really fun
nice nigeria habari is that your name or
your locale
great india mambo
this is what i was hoping for this is
always amazing isn't it to see places
from all around the world anybody else
want to jump in we've got uh what 60
people are so on the call would be fun
to see who all 50 people on the call
nigeria again malaysia
relocated to the uk i hope that's going
well for you cameroons and this is this
is fascinating
thank you all you know at pine and keep
going please don't don't stop because
i'm talking at pine biotech we are
really interested to know the makeup of
our audience so we thought you might be
also i've got a little poll set up and
unfortunately i don't have the official
zoom
poll but we're gonna put a little poll
in the chat box
and we would like to see
uh some more information from you so
this is the
poll
and you could just copy and paste one of
those or if you happen to have two or
more things like if you're both an md
and a phd
if you wouldn't mind dropping that in we
would love to see what the makeup of our
audience is and where you are at in your
career
you would be fascinated by that who's
who can chip in and give us some
information on
your current
status
all right pursuing a phd that's
wonderful masters
rissy thank you
phd's a lot of work my brother got a phd
years ago and he always called it piled
higher and deeper i don't know if that's
still the case with getting a phd but
that certainly is
seems like it is pursuing good we've got
a lot of really
high
high achieving people
microbiologist great pursuing a phd
nice well thank you all for that while
we're looking at the poll result results
if you're not yet registered at
learnomicslogic.com
for your free learning portal account
i'd like to encourage you to do that now
i'm going to put a link in the chat box
i don't want to interrupt the poll so
you guys just keep dropping it in but
that is the web address and you can um
again it's free and it sets you on a
path to learning about this fascinating
body of research and discovery so if you
sign up now at learn.omicslogic.com
and click the register for free
button that that'd be great if you could
do that i'm going to close that poll now
so thank you for those of you that
jumped in on that
a lot of people
really going for higher levels and that
is wonderful and those of you that are
maybe still in high school or something
like that and did get a chance to chip
in it's a great field to be looking at
since you're so willing to help i'm
going to do another one
what is your area of interest and data
types so i'm going to put a lead in here
for you so where are you or your
interest are you still exploring are you
into genomics transcriptonomics where
are you at in your path where do you
want to be
what is your interest what is your data
type genomics okay thank you rissy thank
you for participating in the poll
another genomics
fascinating
nice drill down there
epics cool nice nice
these are really great results you know
if if you're wanting to start your
career in this broad field this is
valuable insight to what other people's
are doing what other people are doing
excuse me um anybody else want to chip
in on that we've got a lot of genomics
exploring cerreli if i said your name
right that's great
uh epigenia nice nice all right cool so
what will we hear this afternoon and
feel free to continue with the poll
what will we hear this afternoon
well in the u.s data science has seen
more adoption and more variety so we're
going to hear about some exciting ways
omnicomics data and data science is used
from algorithm development to training
and applications
the need for more user-friendly tools to
facilitate discovery and discussion
around reproducible data analysis
traditional use cases we're going to
look at some increased complexity as
well as the availability of data
and then we're also going to look at new
applications for this data a traditional
as in research in clinical and then
today as in wellness beauty and even
supplements now our first introduction
is one of the masterminds behind this
symposium and the pine biotech
a leading big data organization whose
corporate vision it is to enhance human
health and well-being by enabling
biological research and discovery both
relevant data solutions and support
but before i officially invite elia to
speak i want him to pop in and see the
final results of our next survey which
is going to be kind of related to what
we just did but a little bit different
and i'm going to pop this in here
what is your application area of
interest where are you going to take
this now some of you put that in above
as you listed your
area but if you can
answer that poll we would be interested
in seeing that also
infectious diseases neuroscience
what else we have out there
oncology fascinating good for you guys
that's really
really fascinating
so elia what do you think about these
results what are you starting to see
thank you grant yes first of all it's
really exciting to see such a diverse
background such diverse interests and
i'm sure that today's session will be
informative because we'll speak about
how all of these different types of data
converge
and as you mentioned
interesting new
applications that maybe some of us have
not thought of
but this is definitely exciting
cool well great thank you for that
response and thank you all for for
playing and since you guys have almost
met him i'll do an official
an official official uh introduction uh
one of the tech masterminds behind the
symposium is elia brodsky elia is the
co-founder one of the co-founders of
pine biotech and serves as ceo now his
background is an applied mathematics and
data science and is currently completing
his degree in business and management
from tulane university
he's facilitated and managed
collaborations with researchers at
stanford ucsf louisiana state university
tulane and other academic and pharma r d
teams
mr broski oversees the strategic
development of research projects and
manages the team responsible for
bioinformatics analysis training and
collaborations for biotech ladies and
gentlemen let's kick off our north
american session in our americas session
with elia brodsky elliott did i did i
get all that in there right did i get it
said right
yes i think that was perfect thank you
very much
you're welcome it's all yours
all right i'll share my screen and
welcome everyone this is going to be
another kind of a transition uh into the
rest of the speakers we have an exciting
set of uh topics and speakers that we'll
be hearing from today
and so i am really excited this is the
third time we are doing this uh group
meeting the symposium really it's
supposed to be more of a discussion so
as you've seen up until now we've heard
from our representatives in both india
and africa
really heard some great insights about
how education research are converging uh
what are the needs and interests in
these different regions and i'm hoping
that today we're going to
learn more about some of these topics um
here in our
americas uh section of this
today session and then tomorrow we have
a great lineup of speakers again so
hopefully you will join that for uh join
that discussion as well
so um just kind of like a high level
overview of some of the insights that
i've heard so far
it was really interesting to hear about
the
kind of greater interest and the need
for hybrid education where we see both
online
and in-person education and especially
in the domain of bioinformatics where we
see such
growing amounts of data and growing
complexity of data emerge as the need
for biotechnology and life sciences
degrees to incorporate
bioinformatics and data science training
into that um teaching so i think that is
really relevant to what we're going to
be discussing today
in africa we saw some of the big
challenges that still the continent
experiences with
infrastructure with ability to not only
hear about bioinformatics but use
bioinformatics and actually apply i
think bioinformatics methods to areas of
research that those participants came
and spoke about so we heard about your
interests in environmental sciences
biotechnology infectious diseases
non-communicable diseases right there's
such a wide range of applications for
bioinformatics and so i'm hoping that
today
we'll kind of learn about some new ones
but that
kind of presents a challenge right how
do we actually
learn bioinformatics and align that
learning with those topics of interest
and how do we not only
kind of follow the same technique
that is one
type of an approach for everyone right
how do we personalize and match
the training with interests that all of
you are pursuing so we heard a lot about
that and i i also am learning about it
and it's really interesting uh to
be able to find collaborations as a
result of this discussion because
there's so much i think that we can
benefit from by
joining forces and working to address
these challenges together
so
um another important announcement that
we heard today is the launch of the
india partnership program and dr mohit
mazunder who is based in india spoke
about
our recent developments in developing
these long-term relationships with
universities and building out a whole
pipeline for students not only to be
exposed to bioinformatics but actually
learning to answer biological and
research questions with data
and working together with faculty as
well as mentors from different
institutions
to advance publications to advanced
research projects and also to get
experiences
in
industry
and we also heard about the research
projects that different students are
working on right so we heard about
just a few examples
we have a lot more projects that are
available on our portal
so grant already mentioned
our portal is learn.omicslogic.com
and on that portal you can see the
training that we provide but you will
also see some of the projects that some
of the graduates have completed thank
you jessica for sharing that link in the
chat box you can go
and and kind of check out some of those
new and updated projects
of course the benefit of developing a
project isn't only to complete a
bioinformatics project but it's also to
be able to demonstrate how you can think
critically how you can apply your data
science skills to a new and challenging
topic and how you can actually
be presenting the results of your
research or your analysis in a
meaningful way and i think to facilitate
that we've included some of the judges
today
but we've also seen judges previously
that came from a background in industry
and academia and all kinds of
applications of bioinformatics so really
it's an opportunity to develop your
profile and stand out from the crowd
now we also spoke about
another challenge that i think is varied
across the continent here in the us
and we'll talk about some of those
challenges outside of these major
biotechnology hubs in the us but we also
will hear about uh bioinformatics in
brazil and we heard about bioinformatics
in africa nigeria
we have people here from south uh
africa from
malaysia right from india from all over
the world and so another major challenge
in all of these domains
uh is ability to find mentorship
and opportunities to join a research lab
or even an internship or a job finding a
job
so
recognizing this challenge we want to
really connect
this ability to showcase what you have
done with the opportunities out there
and so we've launched
a job listing
site where over the next few months we
will be interacting with the research
labs with the employers to make sure
that we can build out that pipeline and
that all fits back
into
that long-term partnership program
where universities can join our
community
bring their students to learn about the
basics of bioinformatics for absolutely
free develop an interest in a specific
application
learn from mentors that are experts in
that domain and eventually showcase
their achievements their projects their
skill sets by
demonstrating their projects and
applying for those opportunities so
if you are here from a university
if you manage students if you mentor
students we would be excited to speak to
you uh after this symposium is over
so another important aspect of the
projects that we saw in the project uh
competition that we are holding this
time as well as what we've done in the
previous times is we're going to be
looking to hand out prizes for these
three categories so we have the category
of best technical and research project
our judges are right now evaluating the
projects that were submitted over the
past few months
we have the promising research direction
and the most innovative approach so
these are prizes that are going to be
awarded tomorrow
if you have participated in the showcase
uh please join but also all of you that
are supporting these students that are
showcasing their research projects we
invite you to join tomorrow and really
see who won the prize and and also see
some of our past
participants that have won prizes and
and what they did after they got those
prizes right because they went on to
join uh different programs where they
continue their study um or have you used
it to advance their research careers as
well
now we already spoke
about the significance of industry
participation and so as a part of this
long-term partnership program we're
really working hard to develop
relationships with companies that both
hire and offer resources such as
infrastructure to help advance
bioinformatics and help to prepare
bioinformaticians of the future for the
careers of the future and so we are
excited to now uh work together with a
number of collaborators some of them you
will meet over the next two days
but those include the faba academy they
include companies like google and cam4
therapeutics and others and all these
are areas where bioinformatics is in
very high demand
and a significantly growing industry and
i think you will be able to see that by
looking at
the diversity of the job listings on our
page
and i also want to mention that if you
are here and you have a job opportunity
or an internship
or some kind of an experience that you
would like to share with our
participants please do
submit a job which is
available on that page as well
so what are we going to hear about today
uh today we're going to be talking about
advances in enabling technologies our
mixed research symposium is obviously
based on these different types of omics
data so we're going to be hearing about
how the diversity of instruments we have
now illumina oxford nanopore 10x
genomics recently we heard about
ultimate genomics right so the diversity
of data that is being generated the
decreasing costs that are being
associated with the sample preparation
and sequencing all of this is driving
the need for complex data analysis
cleaning and integration
and importantly in different domains we
will hear about how it varies by
application type so we'll hear for
example about applications in oncology
applications in forensic sciences and
tomorrow we will heard about here about
other applications including for example
in beauty so really a lot of interesting
applications that we need to learn about
and the
the choice of data type the choice of
the sequencing platform as well as how
to manage and analyze such data is what
we're going to be hearing about
now i'm a big believer in user-friendly
tools right we all understand the
significance of knowing mathematics and
knowing statistics and machine learning
and also knowing coding languages
and ultimately you cannot be an expert
in everything i think that this
expectation from
bioinformaticians to be
both very sophisticated engineers data
engineers and expert biologists is just
sometimes unrealistic and so to make
bioinformatics more accessible
more
kind of user friendly we need to make
sure that a lot of these tools can be
used by people with less experience and
so i'm really excited to hear about some
of the updates
that we're going to hear from dr julia
panov who's going to be speaking about
the analysis of bulk and single cell
transcriptomics data
and uh from elizabeth
who is going to be speaking about the
analysis of managed genomic data on the
t by info platform so these are going to
be exciting
sessions where we will hear some of
these important updates and not only
hear about them but hopefully right away
be able to use some of those as well
now i am also excited to announce that
we are going to be hosting a
bioinformatics hackathon so we've
tentatively sent the set the date for
november 17 to 22.
uh where we will get we are going to be
uh hosting a hackathon for omix wellness
and health and the major
target will be
for students from around the world as
our participants here today from africa
from india from the us from south
america to
find each other build a team
and come together to build an
application and so the goal and i hope
that you take this perspective as you
hear some of the speakers that are going
to be speaking just a few more minutes
uh this is an opportunity to identify
a really clear application of omix data
in wellness and health and so i hope
that after today's session we will share
announcements about application process
uh the different resources that we're
going to be making available that will
include computing resources
data sets that you can start working
with
as well as some mentorship and guidance
that we will be making available for
those of you that are interested in this
opportunity
and the winning team is also going to be
getting prizes and recognition for the
application that they built
so let me briefly now describe some of
the speakers that will cover um some
research topics that i think are very
relevant to what we are doing here today
we're going to speak from dr nikolai
oskalkovs who is a senior
bioinformatician at the department of
biology at lund university sweden and
science for life laboratory he is going
to be speaking about machine learning
for multi-omics data integration
now this is a very interesting and hot
topic in bioinformatics so i hope that
we will kind of see the significance of
these challenges that new data types
bring but also to the need in being able
to make sense of how does this data
actually describe biological phenomena
we also talk about
another person who is applying
multi-omics integration or multi-omics
techniques to the area of forensic
sciences and that's where dr sarah
zapico who is an assistant professor in
the department of chemistry and
environmental sciences is going to speak
to us about her current research
but also how she got into this whole
field of bioinformatics because her
background is more on the biology
biochemistry side
and i think that this program the omics
logic program in part was instrumental
in her being able to incorporate
bioinformatics into her work
we will also uh um sorry there's a
mistake on the slide but uh we will also
hear from dr kasturi kanan
it's written on the slide the dr kasturi
kanan who is
an assistant director at the md anderson
cancer center so really excited to hear
from him about his experience in
applying systems biology to
oncology and i think we'll learn a lot
about his area of a specialization as
well
now we're also going to hear from a
clinician
dr luis sakamoto
who is a pediatric oncologist in brazil
and he will be speaking about precision
medicine in pediatric oncology and what
is the state of the art and perspectives
and i think it's important to kind of
see how these different applications are
maybe different by location as well
now before we continue i want to remind
you that we offer code or no code
bioinformatics paths for learning and
mastering bioinformatics and
bioinformatics and so we hope that
anyone here today can participate in at
least some of what we make available by
visiting the
omix logic portal
we welcome everyone to subscribe and
register there for free create a profile
and as this becomes more relevant in
your area of research to start
benefiting from some of the resources
project examples and mentorship
opportunities that we provide so we hope
that really these kinds of programs can
enable research across all of the
regions that we have represented today
we offer big data analysis tools where
you can make sense of complex
relationships between phenotypes and
genotypes we offer mentorship with
experts
and
peer examples that you can learn from
and we're also offering training that is
both a synchronous training that you can
leverage as a
as a a faculty member or even a teacher
and
as a
guided program that you can incorporate
or even offer as a trainer yourself
so one of the important things that we
are moving into is opening up the
omixlogic platform to other participants
so before we move on i just briefly want
to take a pause and
kind of show you
how you also uh can
participate in this today
so
let's go to
learn
comicslogic.com
and you can follow along
so really i'll show some of the benefits
of what you are able to find on our
portal
i'm going to log out and the way to sign
up is simply to go to this link
and you can either
sign in with an account that you already
have or create an account like this and
so i am going to
briefly log in you're welcome to log in
as well
once you log in the benefit is that you
actually get
access to all of these resources
including the t-bind for platform where
you can try out different kinds of demo
pipelines and really explore this whole
path from beginning to the end so we're
just going to take a couple of minutes
to take a look at this
um we offer here courses programs and
projects and i briefly want to show
what do all of these different things
mean so let's say you're interested in
mastering python or r or you want to
learn about single cell rna sequencing
or you have an interest in a specific
project like maybe covet 19.
so this is going to be an easy way where
you can find
any kind of a resource with curated data
sets and case studies that are based on
publications you can also look for
things like
machine learning
in r and maybe you want to learn how to
visualize
and analyze data using complex machine
learning methods so really there's a lot
of different opportunities here and a
simple way to get started is just to
click right here on getting started and
see a collection of courses that are
only around a specific topic
now once you are here
you also have a personal profile on this
profile you can
monitor and share your progress and
achieve levels of expertise that later
on you might be able to showcase if
you're applying for a specific position
so here you will track the coursework
that you are completing
you can also
take mentor-guided programs that are
actually led by an expert in that field
and importantly you can develop an
independent
project
so developing an independent project is
something that is i think critical to
your master mastery of bioinformatics
not only are you going to be able to
show that you've understood the
challenge the problem found a data set
prepared a whole plan for analysis but
you'll be able to showcase what you have
achieved at the end so if you click
right here on the projects tab on top
you'll be able to see some of the
exciting projects that others have
worked on over the past few months
you can see projects in all kinds of
domains from oncology to infectious
diseases to metabolic diseases
neuroscience and others and so as you
can see we also have some features here
that you can comment on other projects
or like them and and highlight them and
that really makes it a much more uh
engaging platform for everyone to
participate in
now you might be asking well but how
many people are actually using uh this
platform at the moment and so you can
always check the activity
on the portal by simply going to the
achievements tab
and you will see that you know it's 11
47 right now just at 11 46 somebody
already learned about bioinformatics how
to get started with bytes and molecules
so you can see that somebody just signed
it up very recently at 11 16 right so
here you can really see a real
time flow of participation and you can
also comment and like this as well as
long as you are signed in
so what the omics logic portal offers
you is a
comprehensive community and set of
resources that you can leverage to learn
and apply bioinformatics
now i also mentioned that we have
this high
priority for making bioinformatics
accessible and user friendly for anyone
that is going to be a part of these
training courses
and that's why we have the t-bound for
platform specifically designed to help
you master analysis of next generation
sequencing mass spec structural biology
and all kinds of phenotypic data types
so on this platform which by the way you
get a free account with if you
uh complete the registration on the onyx
logic portal
here you will get access to complex
pipelines that you can
try to analyze data
you'll be able to interactively create
pipelines that produce results right
away and learn as you go through this
process to really not only be able to
perform the analysis but understand what
goes on at each step of the way
in addition to that you will be able to
compare and contrast how selection of
different algorithms
defines the outcomes of your analysis
and what are the types of uh results
that you will end up getting in the end
so you will see here right away we have
some output data sets that we can
explore
in addition to that you will be able to
store your pipelines for later use and
you'll be able to see how this data
could be explored interactively
something that we will talk about in
today's session in much greater detail
but actually play around with your data
and really understand how can this data
be informed uh informative
for your analysis and for the types of
things that you would like to understand
so really not only are you getting the
direct access to high quality resources
that you can learn from and utilize to
build upon to make your own research
project but also have a set of easy to
use tools that really make this whole
data analysis process much simpler and
user-friendly
in the end
so with that
i do want to briefly mention some of our
initiatives in the u.s
i'm excited about just this year
we have started a series of pilot
projects with an organization called the
national association of idea principal
investigators
this organization brings together
members from 23 states and puerto rico
and includes universities like
university of delaware and university of
hawaii and the university of puerto rico
and many others where students are kind
of outside of these major biotechnology
hubs on the west coast on the east coast
we have many universities that
specialize in biotechnology and have
been able to put together impressive
ecosystems that bring clinical research
biomedical research biotechnology
companies uh funding etc and so these 23
states and puerto rico represent areas
that are underfunded and do not have
access to such high quality resources so
we've been able to partner with this
network and offer virtual summer
programs such as machine learning for
biomedical data
analysis of infectious disease data
oncology as well as our research
fellowship program and we're excited to
see participation from both
research technicians
students and faculty across many of
these areas that were able to
participate and complete successfully
some of these programs
now the next step
as we complete some of this basic
training is to start opening up this
platform to other universities and
students around this
network and so what we'll be focusing on
tomorrow is hearing from some of the
members of this community
from different locations
how they see the challenges associated
with training in bioinformatics and data
science for
uh those who come from a life science
and medical background
and uh how can we actually build a more
consistent high quality
and effective resource to advance
biomedical research across these
these regions
now briefly i want to also mention that
we will be
starting our next cycle of registrations
for the research fellowship program that
is designed to help researchers and
young
researchers and students develop their
bioinformatics skills as they
kind of immerse themselves into research
using bioinformatics and so the goal
there is not so much on skill
it is more on soft skills and critical
thinking
how can you pick out your own data set
how can you
technically define your
research question and really apply your
skills to answer that question with real
data we have heard some great examples
today
but it is a very structured and uh clear
uh process that we have designed over
the last few years
to make sure that anyone without any bio
bioinformatics background can actually
perform such analysis and be successful
at it and so we'll hear a little bit
more about the need for such uh research
experiences tomorrow but um i want to
make sure that you're all aware of this
program and you are able to participate
if this is something that you would like
to do in the next few months
all right finally
my last uh exciting announcement for
today is that uh pine biotech with our
omics logic bioinformatics education
portal has been nominated as the
finalist for the edtech cup and this is
uh hosted by start ed
this is the largest edtech accelerator
in the us
and
they brought together some experts in
education technology and edtech as well
as venture capital from
leading firms that invest in in such
companies and we hope that we can
connect with them to really allow
many more um students to not only
participate but also really advance
their careers and succeed in this field
so
over the next few weeks we'll be sending
out information and announcements and we
really hope that we can get your support
in uh succeeding in this competition
and
getting enough support to really advance
to the next level
so
again thank you for joining today i'm
excited to hear our speakers and i will
pass this on to grant
uh to
talk about what's coming up next